[Müzik]
Oy Yaylalar yay
ına Oy Yaylalar
[Müzik]
Yayla
suyu o
[Alkış]
[Müzik]
o kadar
Yayla yaylalar yay
[Müzik]
Oy Yaylalar
[Alkış]
yaylalar şimdi birlikte bir prova
yapalım
mı bakalım buranın aküsü değil nasılmış
sizin seslerinizde mi duyalım istiyoruz
o yaylalar kısım
ları bitti
[Müzik]
Oy Yaylalar
Çok teşekkürler Çok teşekkür ederiz Hoş
geldiniz Öncelikle Merhabalar Hoş
geldiniz Biz de hoş geldik
İstanbul'dan geldik
sizlerle buluştuğumuz için öncelikle
tedex Ankara ailesine çok çok teşekkür
ederiz sizlerle tanışma fırsatı bulduk
sizlerle buluştuk bugün çok kısa olacak
programımız
bu bizim ikinci kez Ankara ailesi ile
birlikteliğimiz O yüzden çok mutlu ve
heyecanlıyız
organizasyon yapmak gerçekten çok zor
bir iş ama bu işin içinden gerçekten
hakkıyla çıkıyorlar Biz onlara çok
teşekkür ederiz
[Alkış]
Evet samide Gürcü dilinde üç kız kardeş
demek ben şöyle kısaca bir bahsetmek
isterim
Damla Şahin Ben Yudum Şahin kardeşimiz
Tamara Şahin birlikte 2017 yılında
samide'yi kurduk Biz Gürcü bir ailenin
ve müzisyen Bir babanın çocuklarıyız
Dolayısıyla kültürle ve müzikle büyüdük
bu coğrafyanın
Balkanlardan kafkaslara uzanan tüm o
renkli eserleri Gürcü müziğinde var olan
çok sesli polifonik yapıyı çok sesli
şarkı söyleme
üslubuyla bu anlayışlı eserlerimizi
düzenliyoruz bir albüm ve 8 single
çalışması şu ana kadar yayınladık ve
yine aynı heyecanla ve hızla devam
ediyoruz
[Alkış]
[Müzik]
Yayla
çiçeği Yayla çiç
im bana
yuvarlağında gel bana güneş
mi Ay mısın da kurban olayım sana güneş
misin Ay mısın da kurban olayım sana hop
Ray nay nay
[Müzik]
Yaylalar
ını
[Müzik]
Seni kim seni
doğuda
balıdan mı Yurdu seni
doğurana da
[Müzik]
bağlanmıyordu
Hoppa
[Müzik]
lay lay hoparlinger
[Alkış]
yaylalardan başladık Şimdi bizim o
taraflara doğru şöyle bir kuzeye doğru
devam edeceğiz Gürcistan'dan Acara
bölgesinden Gürcüce bir potpori
sözlerinde Sevda'yı buram buram
Yaşadığımız bir eseri seslendireceğiz
[Müzik]
[Alkış]
tekrar görüşmek dileğiyle hoşça kalın
sağlıcakla kalın
[Müzik]